[Music]
so the key question no one doubts that
people who come to counseling or receive
psychiatric services are in great
distress they may be extremely confused
and low in mood has serious relationship
difficulties or disabling panic attacks
and so on sometimes they are tormented
by hostile voices or have terrifying
mood swings but are they suffering from
medical illnesses that need diagnosing
or do we need completely different ways
of understanding their distress which
are not based on diagnosis and if so
what those might those ways be so to be
really really clear the distress is real
there's a lot of muddled thinking about
this isn't that a distress is real the
explanations are up for question two
important messages few people can afford
to give up diagnosis entirely we live in
a diagnostic of a system it is needed or
some something rather similar is needed
for access to benefit services and so on
but people may decide they do not wish
to define themselves and their problems
in this way you may decide I do not want
to take on the belief that I am
suffering from schizophrenia or bipolar
disorder all of us and healthy disorder
all major depressive disorder or any of
that stuff and you do not want to take
on the identity of someone who is
mentally ill which is not a highly
valued identity and comes with many many
significant disadvantages and that
should be up to you you can only make
that choice if you're clear about the
arguments okay but these are very
complex discussions I hope you don't
waste as much time on Twitter as I do
but you can see that it's almost
impossible to raise these questions at
all without being accused as I have on
many many occasions of silencing and
vilifying and attacking service users
and shaming people for taking pills and
all the rest of it it's like and the
underlying message is quite disturbing I
think from some people that we are not
allowed to have these discussions well I
think we have to have these discussions
many times I've been told how device if
it is to have these discussions the most
important discussions that we need to
have our devices by their nature you
know think about abortion and Ireland
you know we have to have these
discussions
but as a society this is a quote from my
book we seem to find it hard to find a
middle ground between you have a
physical illness and therefore your
distress is real and known is to blame
for it and your difficulties are
imaginary and/or your or someone else's
fault and you ought to pull yourself
together are you familiar with that kind
of dichotomy as soon as they ask
questions it's like you're blaming
people undermining them telling to pull
themselves together this is sometimes
called the brain or blame trap
if it's not my brain then I or someone
else must be to blame and we will
further uncomfortable that in America
they call it chemistry or character and
my question is could there be a middle
ground a ground which is about
understanding how people got to the
situations that they're in which doesn't
involve blame but doesn't simply
attribute it to some hypothesized but
never evidenced malfunction in their
brains or whatever a lot of these
arguments came to the head came to our
head with the publication of dsm-5 in
May 2013 most of you will know that DSM
the Diagnostic and Statistical Manual of
Mental Disorders is the sometimes called
the Bible that lists all our 400 or more
ways in which we can apparently be
mentally ill all disordered
about 1900 three ways and now there's
400 so something interesting has
happened and there is an equivalent
called ICD or more or less equivalent
which is drawn up by the World Health
Organization but both DSM and ICD are
used kind of internationally now what's
very interesting about the current
debate is that a lot of the strongest
criticism is coming from the world's
most powerful influential psychiatrists
some of whom involved in drawing up
these manuals this is not as perhaps
it's sometimes seen in the 60s the
Maverick anti psychiatrists so-called
this is the very people who drew up
these manuals in the first place so
here's a collection of some of my
favorite quotes dr. Allan Francis chair
of the DSM for committee DSM additions
are revised every 10 or 20 years of
those so dsm-5 is the fifth edition you
know you're in trouble with your fifth
edition one for your chief critics is
the chair of the DSM for committee dsm-5
will radically and recklessly expand the
boundaries of psychiatry there is no
reason to believe that dsm-5
saiful scientifically sound those are
strong words you know I get into trouble
when I see that kind of thing
he's the man who drew it up he should
know the former director of the National
Institute for mental health that world's
largest funding body for mental health
dsm is totally wrong and absolute
scientific nightmare dr. Thomas Ince all
patients deserve better the weakness is
its lack of validity I won't bore you of
details about reliability versus
validity but if you think for a second
there could not be a bigger weakness and
lack of validity in in essence it's
saying we do not know whether this
reflects anything that's going on the
actual in the real world in an unguarded
moment in an interview for a new
newspaper dr. Alan Francis admitted
there is no definition of a mental
disorder I mean you just can't define it
it's [ __ ] so I find this very
curious because we still are in age and
where people are routinely every day
thousands of people are told you have
bipolar disorder you have schizophrenia
and how many of them are also given the
addendum but by the way you know that's
[ __ ] not many of them number than I
suggest so this is the that there is no
more important question in psychiatry
and I don't just mean psychiatrists when
I say that I mean the whole mental
health industry than the one of
diagnosis because everything depends on
this if these are not medical illnesses
in some senses everything has a question
or language of course but the main
interventions we offer which tend to be
medical ones the main professions are
involved doctors and nurses the main
settings we see people in hospitals and
clinics you know everything depends on
that so as dr. Peter Breggin who's an
American the critical psychiatrist has
said if diagnoses cannot be demonstrated
to be reliable and valid we are left
asking whether we're left with a medical
specialty that does not treat medical
illnesses can you see how that might be
a little problematic you know that is
what we are faced with that those that
is the the dilemma that we're currently
in and hence these headlines being a
rather sad person a very narrow
interests as my family and friends often
tell me I have a large collection of
these
which you don't need to read but they're
coming out every month these you know an
awful lot of people have noticed that
Western psychiatry is in crisis
psychiatry thing crisis psychiatry seems
to have lost its way again it's not
psychic psychiatrists as such but the
whole mental health enterprise is the
country dying it's time to reach beyond
diagnostic dependence this is from a
psychiatrist himself so again I want to
make the point that many psychiatrists
themselves are equally concerned about
this and have been very brave I think in
speaking out about it it's probably
easier for them to do than me to do so I
respect their courage and you know there
are serious problems but how many people
in the room have somehow from somewhere
received the distinct impression that
depression for example is caused by a
chemical imbalance yes now I wonder
where you got that from because there is
an extraordinary degree of backsliding
again at the very top of the psychiatric
profession this guy is a very senior
American psychiatrist the chemical
imbalance theory was never a real theory
nor was it widely propounded by
responsible practitioners in the field
of psychiatry that's extraordinary how
can this delusion idea have spread so
fast and so quickly and further than
that
this is backtracking on a major scale he
has alleged that the idea that
psychiatrists once told people that low
serotonin was a cause of depression and
the antidepressants created this
chemical imbalance is now said to be a
false narrative invented by
anti-psychiatry now activists that's
people like you and me folks okay so
we're kind of left in a limbo state
whereas David dr. David Cook for the
chair of the dsm-5 Committee says we've
been telling for patients or several
decades were waiting for biomarkers
actual concrete evidence of things we
have wrongly been told off fact for
decades it's a chemical imbalance
there's some genetic contribution we're
still waiting and in fact again in the
world's largest mental health funding
body they recognize this they are
funding research now not based on what
causes bipolar disorder or what are the
causal factors in schizophrenia because
if these are not valid categories
they're not a good starting point for
research so they are not accept
in Grant's on that basis they're
accepting grants and applications on the
basis of things like that cut across
diagnoses like you know high arousal or
anxiety or something like that but
they're not giving up
they are the diagnostic enterprise in
their view is not something needs to be
abandoned they are pouring millions of
dollars into what they say is going to
be the far we're finally going to get
the the scientifically validated
diagnostic system based on their website
on the front page it says on the
assumption that mental disorders are
brain disorders I find this very strange
I don't think you have to be a very
senior researcher to work out that
logically it's not a very good idea to
start by assuming what you're trying to
prove we do not know that these are
brain disorders but you can see there's
very much stood in that mindset so we're
left with circular arguments why does
this person hear voices fee so desperate
because they have schizophrenia or
depression how didn't have schizophrenia
or depression because they hear voices
also definitely insert any diagnosis you
like you know apart from a few like sort
of Alzheimer's and things which of
course we have evidence of you know
brain dysfunction why this person have
such awful mood swings because they have
bipolar disorder how do you have bipolar
disorder because they have such awful
mood swings and so on for modder bates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institutes of Arts and ideas at IAI
TV
you